it seems now to be so devastatingly
regular yet more extreme weather
multiple states of emergency declared
records broken again
across several american states emergency
services have been stretched to their
limits
rescuing people who had retreated up the
top floors of many homes were the only
safe place
people were ferried to drier ground
through the morning whole families young
and old
this is elizabeth new jersey in a glance
now and you'd think that nothing had
happened but look more closely because
just hours ago this was a torrent of
water all these cars had water high up
on their sides the houses all around are
flooded as well an extraordinary level
of water over such a short period of
time
this rock all the cars is staying still
but on the other block
several cars was floating on top and
hitting somebody else
the river here burst its banks filling
the surrounding streets in minutes the
power of the water is so clear
within a few hours of this happening it
was clear too
that people had died
a long line of evacuees now wait to be
re-homed this is my first time ever
experiencing anything like this
so how are you feeling
um i'm a little bit scared
pretty full-on right yeah
but the cat's all right yep she's crying
though yeah what's the plan now
well i guess they're going to put us in
hotels i really don't know they're going
to evacuate us they're making us all
leave and i guess they're going to put
us in hotels for
temporarily
but much of this effort took place
before daylight an extraordinary
multi-agency multi-state rescue
operation responding to an unprecedented
dump of water
but it wasn't just the volume of water
it was the speed it came highways
overwhelmed in minutes
and the railways too
[Music]
this was the new york city subway
flooding on a level which left people
stunned
[Music]
the u.s national weather service
declared the city's first ever flash
flood emergency
this is what climate change looks like
guys this is what climate change does
and this wasn't just rainfall
even having traveled across north
america ida was still producing winds
strong enough to do this a tornado
taking away the only cover some
residents had this is hillsborough to
the southwest of new york city
watching all this as well as the
flooding in the south and the huge fires
in the west president biden he addressed
the multiple weather events from the
white house
the past few days of hurricane ida
and the wildfires in the west and the
unprecedented flash floods in new york
and new jersey
is yet another reminder that these
extreme storms
and the climate crisis crisis are here
the sun is shining now across the east
coast
the storm has swept out into the
atlantic but the damage to homes and
infrastructure will take considerable
time to fix